[Music]
recently China has combined two
practices to make significant political
and territorial gains in Asia without
crossing the threshold at the open
conflict with the United States first
since the 1990s China has focused on
low-cost ways to disrupt disable and
deny us ability to operate in the region
instead of trying to compete directly
with US power projection capabilities
China's ballistic and cruise missiles
for example hurt the u.s. ability to
come to the aid of Japan Taiwan or the
Philippines in the case of a conflict
with China second since 2009 instead of
direct confrontation to push the United
States out of the asia-pacific China has
engaged in activities below the
threshold of conflict for example China
has increased the risk to the United
States of operating in the South China
Sea by harassing us vessels and aircraft
with non-military platforms to maintain
a degree of deniability and discourage a
counter response as a result China has
gained more power and territorial
control of Asia without recourse do you
think the United States should push back
morgan's China let us know in our poll
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI